properties inequalities this is how I do
inequalities work because they're quite
different in some ways to equations
let's start with the stuff that's in
common okay
so personally I've got one two three
four four categories of properties and
the first one has to do with constants
now I should say right from the get-go
that all of these remember this is
harder extension one so therefore we're
in the real world here all of our
numbers that we're going to deal with
are real and that's very significant so
keeping in mind that we're dealing with
like real numbers and that kind of thing
the first thing which is in common with
equations is if you've got an inequality
you can do addition and subtraction of
closets because subtraction is just a
specialized form of a different it's
just the addition of a negative number
good morning I'm just going to call it
an addition okay so I'm going to keep on
saying something like this right if
you've got two quantities and you know
that they relate in this way then that
implies something else and the the
notation I use for implies is it power
okay so I'm gonna read this off a is
greater than B it implies that if you
add a constant to both sides the
inequality still holds okay so that's
just addition pleasure in much the same
way again just like in the equation
world you can do multiplication right by
a constant now if a is greater than B
then that implies a X is greater than B
X in a particular case where where is
this true the X is positive right
okay but of course it also means if X is
not positive or rather if X is negative
cuz if x equals zero then there's a big
development then you turn the inequality
around right so this is the first place
that we discover oh yeah you're not in
Kansas anymore
edik sorry it's a Wizard of Oz this is
our first clue that are yes despite how
many similarities there are two
equations there are some things make you
deposit because the two things are the
same anymore you can't just treat them
exactly identically okay that's the
first e about constants now secondly
I'll hardly call it a category but it's
worth oh it's worth right now because I
don't I couldn't see it fitting into the
UM the other category is easily
reciprocals now we've talked very
briefly about this before good morning
but if a is greater than B what does
that imply if I take reciprocals of both
sides which is that implied okay good so
if you've got a V a big nut but B being
small enough then a big denominator
makes the overall numbers smaller okay
so that's why we have the Illinois face
in the other direction and again this is
kind of like what's happening over here
right you see it's multiplication of
division and it's like look if you've
got a equals B right
if you're an equation world that you can
take reciprocals of both sides and they
stay the same
okay but here something is different
inequalities okay right number three I'm
gonna sit over here and I'm not on the
floor here my next category is all about
squares okay so we've looked at
constants we've very briefly looked up
reciprocals now think about squares now
this will take a little more thought
okay so first thing you know we've been
thinking about doing things to both
sides which is kind of like from your
equation way of thinking okay so this is
like multiplying by the other side's
adding both sides and take reciprocals
of most
what about squaring both sides come in
good morning
okay so okay let's take let's see now
I'm going to stop her here but let add a
second thing an extra little detail I
want to think now about the positive
numbers because you often see this
phrase which means okay I've got a
relationship between this pair of
numbers I know which one is bigger but I
also want to say hey by the way they're
both positive okay so if I know this
what does it imply about this inequality
here and what happens if I square both
sides what happens to the inequalities
okay it's it preserves the direction of
the inequality right it preserves the
dirt remove equality because if a is a
bigger number you're multiplying that by
a bigger number again right so this guy
is gonna save a bigger site that's all
fine all right so that's what happens
when you square both sides these
monitors because start saying
yes yes you're right no no no no no no I
was right the third time because if
you've got a high and a water for
instance half the water when you square
this you're gonna get so much that you
just write it down uh-huh is bigger than
a quad up and then when you square you
get a corner and 16 which is still which
is still fine that's a really bad seize
okay yeah happy yeah okay good oh now I
need actually need the spaces so I'm
gonna get rid of it I now want to think
in this one's again a little trickier
River I said it's important that we're
all dealing with real numbers here okay
so therefore when you square things and
you know you're in the real world that
means you can't ever go negative right
kind of it go negative there's a lot of
ways you can apply that okay so the most
general way is saying it so I'm gonna
say squares and reals
that's the ohms so long as you're
dealing with real numbers and in this
idea here we're always dealing with real
numbers then anything you like anything
you like if you square it you're gonna
stay add zero or above right so I'm
going to just state it as an obvious
thing here even though it's kind of like
overarching assumption now you can take
that idea and you can kind of um you can
sort of use it in lots of different ways
right so for example there are like
variations on this you can put different
things into a and B and form slightly
different equations that basically take
advantage of the same property okay so
for example let's just say you know in
this moment and B they can be positive
or negative but maybe I want it so this
is more like a difference that looks
more like a difference it could be a
difference already
if B is a negative number it could be a
difference but I want to write it in
such a way that's more obvious so
sometimes you'll see this name it's more
easy to it's easier to start to get to
put
result by sign this way you can put in
other wheat wacky things into a and B so
long as you stay in the real world okay
so another common example would be this
square root of a square root of 8 or
even the difference between those things
okay because I'm staying in the real
world the square root of real number has
to be real right yes
we've looked at public some inequalities
other things like the triangle
inequality
they tend to come up in like geometry
basically like you think of the vectors
and how they relate to each other this
look like the modulus of this come in
good morning
the modulus of this has to be less than
modulus because of the relationship
these complex numbers on the I get
diagram so straight answer is yes but
you don't think about them generally you
don't think about the Contra breaker you
think about them geometrically that's
the whole point of complex numbers
because like I can view these numbers in
relation to each other in a visual way
okay it's worth saying you can't do them
algebraically but it's almost always
longer what gonna burn and just harder
to see what you're supposed to do
whereas like usually in complex numbers
Ella I could just draw a rhombus draw a
parallelogram and see how things relate
to each other
great question all right what will be
underneath squares and I call this a
squares of conjugates
okay so so I want you to note this
identity I'll actually want you to think
here we do it back to what we did on
some front of roots okay sometimes you
had to say
I came something like this it relates to
this conjugate being squared if you add
or subtract something to sort of
compensate okay because obviously these
are not actually the same so if I figure
out like what do I have to add this in
order to get to that yes is it okay for
a big because like this is a squared
plus the to a B plus B Square this is a
squared minus 2 a B right so I've got to
add a to a be first to make that 0 and
then I have to add another one to get to
this thing right so this is plus 4 a big
does that make sense okay pause for a
minute look at this line and look how it
relates to this thing which I just wrote
a second so what is this line saying
this line is saying you've got this
square right which is this thing for
something else that I know the smallest
it can possibly be is 0 does that make
sense like I would expect that this
should not be 0 there is only one value
that makes it 0 by the way what's that
Daddy what condition is it if a and B
are the same number then this is zero
okay we have our way of saying that by
the way you might learn it in a
different color jot this down over on
the side this guy over here for you
that's a lot of typos so he makes me all
squared it's greater than or equal to
zero right non-negative as opposed to
positive right but there's only a single
way that that could finally hit the
boundary zero and what this stands for
is if and only if right it's the only
way that this can be I suppose because
of mathematicians are so tired of
writing and really
if they like I keep writing this so they
come up with an agreement okay so okay
so no right as in like the actual
letters of the so yeah I'm not gonna try
and justify here everyone's call you out
with that every time I read it like I
know what at night that I know what it
means I mean I read it in a proof I'm
still like the type it looks it just
looks like anyway yeah all of that just
to say but this thing here it's almost
always going to be a positive number
right that means that you've got this
being something plus something else
something and then bigger right so
therefore out of this line putting this
and this blue thing together I can write
it in equality right n plus P all
squared
has somebody greater than or equal to
thank you do you see my logic
think think think this is now like we
said all your inner corners a little bit
different to equations okay it'll all
these are quite different to your
questions think about how this works
think about induction proofs where
you've had this before we're like oh I
just had to realize there was something
here that could only ever make this
bigger or stay where it is bigger or
stay where it is is that latent so this
square of a conjugate this is a really
helpful result it'll come up quite a bit